Well, thanks, uh, everyone for joining
today. I know we're on day 4 of, uh,
reinvent in Las Vegas, so I know you guys got a lot
to choose from. So really appreciate you making
it out to Mandalay Bay to join me for this session.
Uh, so today we're gonna talk about how you
can master your carbon footprint using the AWS
customer carbon footprint tool. So
my name is Alexis Bateman. I head up our AWS
sustainability tech team. Uh, what,
what does that team do? So we actually are
the enabling team behind a lot of our sustainability
goals. So our, our renewable
energy goals are water positive, our net
zero carbon. So we're sort of the underlying
enable enabling, uh, team.
And we also support the customer carbon footprint
tool that all customers can access in the
console. So we're sort of like the backbone
of the of that work, uh, so
today in the next 20 minutes, um, we're
gonna go through a little bit about how we
actually built the customer carbon footprint
tool, what powers it, and then I, I do
wanna send you along
to potentially go over to the expo where we actually
have a demo of the customer carbon footprint
tool there, and you can actually. Go and have
a a complete walk through, uh, with some of my
teammates. So that would be a great thing to end the
day with if, if you, if you're interested in its peak
today. So we'll go through sort of our
top line
sustainability objectives. Then I'll, I'll
show you a little bit about how we built the
what I like to call the guts of the tool, and then,
uh, we'll kind of wrap up with, uh,
uh, sending you over to the expo when you have a chance
later today as we're wrapping up, uh, reinvent
so. So
what the customer carbon footprint tool is really
a representation of our sustainability
objectives at AWS.
So we have,
uh, we are, uh, a climate pledge signatory.
So the climate pledge was,
uh, founded in 2019 in partnership
with Amazon and the, uh, nonprofit
organization Global Optimism. And so we
are a signatory along with other 591
other companies that have the same goal
to be net zero carbon by 2040.
So at AWS we do this in a couple of
different ways, uh, some of which is our carbon-free
energy and efficiency objectives. So,
uh, in 2023 we actually met
our goal to be, uh, to have 100%
renewable energy, uh,
several years early in 2023. Um,
we do this in a couple of different ways. So we have also
our power usage effectiveness which is,
uh, measures our energy overhead. So the,
uh, PE, uh, perfect PUE score
is, uh, 1.0, and so
the industry average is. 1.25.
We're sitting at about 1.15. So that
means we're performing really well. And so when
we're talking about PUE, this is actually how we're
powering our data centers, the energy we
source to power,
how efficiently operate operate those, and
then that feeds directly into the AWS services
that we offer our customers every day.
We also,
uh, have our circularity program. So
this is how we actually reuse and
take back components that we use to build our
data centers, our hardware that goes into
the servers that actually power. Our compute
and so, uh, as of, uh, since
2023 we've recovered over 23
million different components and actually
was able to repurpose them and take them
out of sort of the end of life and and reuse and
recycle.
Uh, we also have our water positive
objective and so we have a goal to be
water completely water positive by 2030
and so this what is water positive means? That means
we're actually replacing more water than we actually
use in our data centers so we're about 53%.
Of the way there and so that happens
across a couple of different ways. We operate our
data centers extremely efficiently. We have
recycling and then we also have water replenishment
programs that we work on with communities where
we operate. So we're about 53% there.
We have a couple more years until we get the 100%
in 2030.
Um, we also publish our water usage
effectiveness score, which is also industry leading
and is what we can, is how you can
kind of capture how we're performing at a regional level, and
this is, uh, publicly available
information. Uh, so
we, we are doing this at very large
scale. So AWS operates at
a, a large, uh, scale. So
we are actually, uh, operating in 117
availability zones, over 245
countries and territories, uh, 37
geographic regions, and, uh,
we, we are also. Uh,
offering, uh, 4.1 times,
uh, at times more than actual on-premise
computes. So this is sort of how our
customers we're supporting them by operating at
this scale,
uh, operating more efficiently, um,
and, and actually able to support
our customers and their sustainability objectives
by running on AWS.
So now I'm gonna dive a little bit into how we
actually built the customer carbon footprint tool and
how, what, what actually powers the, the
underneath, sort of like how we actually generate
those numbers.
So you know, I, I, I maybe
here in the audience some of you guys are familiar with how
you're kind of calculating carbon footprint. If you're not,
you know, I'll give you a little bit of a rundown of how we do
that, but we, it's, uh, essentially it's
sort of like a, a common data flow where we're actually
ingesting
millions of data sets from around the company.
So this is
anything from, you know, component level
information about our hardware and how we build our servers
all the way to, uh, the cement that
goes into our data centers that we're actually. Bu il ding
it out so we ingest all those different
data sets and we have to go through a process of
what we call it sounds a little biological but
which it is, which is carbonating that so actually
translating that that
information into carbon numbers and so we have to
model and transform that. We actually have a
team of scientists that
model the different components and servers
and different
materials that we use to build our, our, our
data centers and the energy we power to actually
make we translate this in. The carbon emissions so we
can actually understand how we're performing, of
course, you know, operating at the scale we have to persist
and govern govern our data as we
would in any scenario.
And then of course the, the step that makes it out
to the customer carbon footprint tool is
an allocation model. So we are actually
generating the total footprint measurement
of AWS and then we need to go through
a process of actually allocating that to
customers based on their usage, so how
much they use different AWS services.
And of course the, the kind of last step which would
be the interface that you might see in
the billing console would be analyze
and act so you're able to actually see, uh,
how, uh, your usage of AWS
services and what is the carbon
representation of that on a monthly basis
and so you can actually see the breakout of
that across our different regions, uh,
and, and, um, uh, and actually
be able to use that in, in terms of how you're
leveraging AWS.
So what, what are some of the different input
sources I touched on them a little bit, but just to kind of
give a, a more visual representation.
So the types of data that we actually need
to, to, to actually, uh, uh,
carbonate to generate the customer carbon footprint
tool, this would be anything from our, our
hardware components, uh, and our
processes, our data center building and
equipment.
Uh, could be the energy consumption
that we're actually using within our data centers
and of course,
uh, what type of energy we're using.
So as I talked,
started the talk, we, um, actually,
you know, are powering a lot of both our renewable
energy and carbon-free energy sources, uh,
uh, such as wind and solar and other,
um, and then of course, you know, as I was talking
about our water positive program, we have water usage, so
we need. To get all of this data
to be able to generate our corporate carbon footprint
and then allocate it to our customers in
the customer carbon footprint tool. So
what does this look like? So we actually have a
sustainably data platform that we have
built internally that power
that ingest all of this data goes through
complex model and orchestration processes
to actually put that entire footprint
together. So this is driven, of course by
the. Goals that we've taken at the top line AWS
objective and then we actually have
uh scientific methodology that we've
uh partnered with our scientists to actually
generate these numbers and this is uh
something that actually creates the deep rigor
of how we're actually calculating our carbon, our
carbon footprint and this is actually,
um, we've done this in a very,
uh, deep and scientific way largely because.
We use it both for to actually generate
the footprint that goes out to the customer carbon footprint
tool, but we also use it to make internal
decisions about how we're designing our
server racks, how, what, what components
we're procuring, right? So the more that we
understand the sustainability impact of all
those different, uh, processes we're conducting
across the company, we can make better and informed
decisions on continuing to drive down our carbon
footprint. And of course,
uh, we use this in a variety of different
ways and so I kind of touched on it a little bit
just now, but, uh, we actually have
something called our glide path. This is when
we talk about a glide path that's how we forecast
out to 2040 so it helps us understand
how we're doing and how close we are getting as
we go through sort of like the next few
years. And so if we're seeing that we're
underperforming in a certain area we're able. To
make different investment decisions, for instance,
in emerging technologies that we wanna
invest in and actually
accelerate how we're decarbonizing, for
instance, some of our, our hardware and our
servers and other materials that we use every day,
uh, we can also use it for sustainability optimization
decisions. So how do we actually optimize,
for instance, the energy use and, and how we're
buying energy and partnering with utility
providers and so actually you. Using that to understand
some of those partnerships we're developing around the world,
um, we, of course, uh, as any
company we have corporate re regulatory
reporting that we need to abide by in all the regions
that we operate. And then of course the,
the one that, uh, I've been talking about
is our customer facing metrics which is
our customer carbon footprint tool which is the public
representation of, uh, of, of
these numbers, and
it's something every customer can access in,
in the billing console.
So, uh, oops, yeah, no,
it, so it just as
like an example to walk through,
uh, we have, for instance, this is a, a
fictional scenario, of course, trying to be a,
a little festive here. So hypothetically
if we have, if we're sourcing energy from
the North Pole, North Pole 1 kilowatt
hour, right, we actually have to take that
data. So this is uh again a fictional scenario
and actually ingest the data,
and this is, uh, frequently ingested
data that we actually then have to carbonate, so. Using,
uh, you know, our scientific methodology
in this case for something like energy,
right, we have a publicly available emissions
impact factor that is regionally sourced and regionally
relevant, and from there that actually
translates into,
you know, how we're actually generating, uh,
energy and the carbon emissions impact of that
energy usage in our, our data centers every
day. This then, of course, uh, you know, as,
as I just went through kind of feeds into
these downstream, uh,
downstream decision scenarios that we need to inform.
So what does this look like? How do we actually do this at
scale? So you know, we are,
uh, you know, a very large enterprise and
so when we actually have to compute our footprint,
we have to, uh, uh, do this
at scale. So we're actually operating 250,
250 ETL pipelines. Uh,
we, we actually support 51 terabytes
of data, and that's growing every single day.
So this, this input of the data actually allows
us to continue to get more
decision making, more granular. Information about how
we're supporting our sustainability
objectives. We also have 800
managed data sets,
uh, 300 ingested data sets,
and 30,000 daily queries of
that data. So
this is, for instance, any of our internal partners
that need to make decisions about procurement,
about optimization decisions, about planning,
they're actually querying this data to understand
and, and actually make, uh, informed
choices about how we drive sustainability
across the company.
And of course you know we abide
by our same architectural principles we sup we've
offered to our customers right to actually develop
this and and um put this in
front of you as the customer carbon footprint
tool so you know we
know that we can't just, uh, put data
out there we have to make sure it's, it's, you know, a
scalable. That we have we're we're
leveraging some of our AI tooling to drive insights
and enable our, our internal
customers to actually query the data.
Of course we have to continue to get higher
and higher quality data so
uh, you know, the, the old adage
of what you can't measure, you can't manage,
um. So this is actually when
we're continuing to drive decisions we
actually get more and more granular data
that is higher quality so that when we make
decisions on top of that it's, it's actually driving
down carbon emissions.
We are, you know, security is paramount. We need, we need
to continue to be obsessive about our
security, making sure we're handling data at scale,
and then of course that the, the data is actually
actionable, uh, so you know, we, in,
in a, in original, you know, so in years
ago, right, we might have been able to generate
a dashboard and say, all right, let's make some decisions
out of. Top of that, that is no longer
sort of like how we need to operate we need to make sure
that the data is accessible, that,
uh, all of our internal and external customers
are able to access this information
and use it to make their decisions.
Sometimes we're piping it directly into some of the
downstream systems, for instance, like our
product life cycle management, other areas where,
for instance, our hardware engineers can make decisions
around what kind of components they're using
and buying and of course how we actually
design our systems is, is resource
efficient as possible so we.
Use, uh, fundamental guidance from the well architected
pillar to actually design our systems and,
and, and, and actually build out our
own infrastructure to support the customer carbon
footprint tool.
So this is sort of like a, like a quick
run through of, of how we've actually built the guts.
I would, um,
you know, in, in our, in our final minutes
together, uh, kind of could do
some, uh, final recommendations about
how we actually do this at scale. So,
um, you know, we have built this for our
external customers like yourself
in terms of the. Customer carbon footprint tool that
that is available in the billing console.
So we, we talk, we are obsessive
about knowing what our customers need every day,
what do they need to actually drive the decisions
that they need to use their carbon emissions. So whether
that be regulatory reporting, whether they
wanna make that more actionable. So when we're
building out these systems, we actually have different,
uh, input mechanisms like product feature
requests like our customer roundtable that we
are working with customers every day,
uh, to actually build this out and, and serve the
serve it, um.
Serve their needs, um, you know, as
we've, if you, if, as I've gone through how we actually
calculate this at, at scale,
right, we don't, I, I wouldn't expect everyone would have to,
uh, uh, do this themselves at
that type of scale, but, you know,
every day when you're thinking about how to
actually calculate carbon footprint, you can
start small,
uh, thinking about how you're actually looking at one
activity, uh, layering as I went
through that one scenario, an emissions
impact factor generating the emissions of one scenario,
and then it, it tallies up into our entire
total footprint.
Um, we build our system for evolution
and scale. We
intend over time to continue to make sustainability
at the heart of every decision we make across
AWS. And so how do we actually
build our data systems and our supporting
infrastructure so we can feed that into every
different, uh, activity we, we conduct
across the business. So we've built this so that we can actually
scale this out over time.
Uh, and then of course, um, do
you want to, um, uh, just
kind of obligatory, you know, this is, uh, this
is sort of our obligatory in slide, but level up
your skill on AWS skillBuilder, so this
is really cool.
Make sure you take some time to, um,
actually go and access the, the SkillsBuilder
and, and continue to evolve and, and innovate
on AWS.
Um, I will leave us
a little early, but I wanna thank you. I know you
have a lot of choices about what you can come and, and
see. Uh, I, um,
I do. Highly recommend you go over to the sustainability
section of the showcase. So if you look
at, you know, the entire expo hall, there's
a big overhang in theater 3 that
says sustainability. We have, uh,
a real live demo of the customer carbon footprint
tool where we can help you kind of find where
it lives in billing console, go through all
the different features that we actually have,
and, you know, talk to, for instance, Marta Fraga,
who's, uh, our product manager on the customer
carbon footprint tool. So I definitely go over there. There's also
additional demos about how you can actually
leverage AWS native native service.
Is to, uh, build more other scenarios
around circularity and biodiversity, so I'd
go and spend a little bit of time there.
Um, if you have any questions, please do stick
around. I would love to answer them and, uh,
take some time to rate the app. We wanna continue to
have sustainability content at Reinvent,
so 5 out of, it's a, it's like a Yelp rating,
5 out of 5 stars please, um,
because we wanna make sure we can continue to tell
some of the innovative stuff we're doing in sustainability
and of course, you know,
continue to kind of share out how we're building
this for our customers. So thank you very much.